HANNITY IS NEXT.
♪
>> Sean: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
THIS IS HANNITY.
WE START BEFORE SUNRISE HA
HEAVILY ARMED FBI AGENTS
DRESSED IN FULL TACTICAL
GEAR SURROUNDING THE HOME OF
A 66-YEAR-OLD MAN DRAWING
THEIR WEAPONS, POUNDING ON
THE DOOR AND THEY TOOK HIM
INTO CUSTODY.
THIS WAS NOT A SUSPECTED
MURDERER, DRUG KING PIN, NOT
A PART OF THE MOB.
THIS WAS ROGER STONE ACCUSED
OF MAKING A FALSE STATEMENT
TO CONGRESS.
NOW, STONE IS JUST THE
LATEST AMERICAN TO BE
PERSECUTED BY ROBERT
MUELLER'S WITCH-HUNT BECAUSE
OF HIS CONNECTION TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
NOW, COMING UP TONIGHT, LONG
TIME ROGER STONE CONFIDANTE
AND FELLOW MUELLER TARGET
PERSON NUMBER ONE IN THIS
INDICTMENT.
JEROME CORSI WILL JOIN US
FOR EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW.
BIG NEWS, WE START WITH THE
PARTIAL GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN,
PRESIDENT TRUMP ANNOUNCED
TODAY THAT AFTER 35 DAYS A
DEAL HAS BEEN REACHED TO
REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT
TEMPORARILY UNTIL FEBRUARY
THE 15TH.
HE IS GIVING CONGRESS NOW
THREE WEEKS TO AGREE ON
LEGISLATION TO BUILD THE
WALL, SECURE OUR BORDERS,
AND HE WAS SPEAKING EARLIER
TODAY FROM THE ROSE GARDEN
AND HERE'S WHAT THE
PRESIDENT HAD TO SAY.
>> IT'S JUST COMMON SENSE
WALLS WORK.
THAT'S WHY MOST OF THE
DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS HAVE
VOTED IN THE PAST FOR BILLS
THAT INCLUDE WALLS AND
PHYSICAL BARRIERS AND VERY
POWERFUL FENCES THESE
BARRIERS ARE MADE OF STEEL,
HAVE SEE THROUGH VISIBILITY
WHICH IS VERY IMPORTANT AND
ARE EQUIPPED DR. SENSORS
MONITORS AND CUTTING EDGE
TECHNOLOGY.
>> Sean: WE HAVE THE REAL
BEHIND THE SCENES STORY.
NOBODY ELSE IN THE MEDIA
WILL TELL YOU.
NUMEROUS DEMOCRATS, BOTH IN
THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE FOR
THE LAST TWO WEEKS, THEY
HAVE BEEN SPEAKING TO THEIR
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES.
THEY HAVE BEEN ASKING THEM
TO BROKER THIS THREE-WEEK
OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT THE
WALL AND NEGOTIATE OTHER
PARTIES LIKE ANOTHER ISSUES
LIKE DACA AND DREAMERS.
THEY HAVE BEEN BEGGING THEIR
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES TO
MAKE THAT DEAL WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
SO THE PRESIDENT, WELL, HE
SHOWED LEADERSHIP.
ROSE ABOVE THE PARTISAN
BICKERING IN THE SWAMP
OFFERING RELIEF TO FEDERAL
WORKERS ALL WHILE STICKING
TO HIS COMMITMENT TO RESTORE
OTHER BORDER.
NO AMBIGUITY IN THREE WEEKS
IF CONGRESS CANNOT DO THEIR
JOB, SECURE A DEAL TO
PROTECT OUR BORDERS, THEN
THE PRESIDENT WILL DO WHAT
HE LAWFULLY HAS THE RIGHT TO
DO AND THAT'S DECLARE A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY AND HE
WILL BE BUILDING THE WALL
WITH FUNDS THAT HE ALLOCATES
MOST LIKELY FROM THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT.
THIS IS, INDEED, A REAL
CRISIS.
IN THREE WEEKS HE WILL
DECLARE A NATIONAL EMERGENCY
AND, LOOK AT WHAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS DONE UP UNTIL
NOW.
HE HAS OFFERED CONCESSIONS,
THINGS THE DEMOCRATS SAY
THEY WANTED.
DACA, DREAMERS, TPA.
IS HE STANDING UP FOR LIFE
VS. DEATH.
TO HIM, HE HAS BEEN ARGUING
SAFETY AND SECURITY FOR THE
PEOPLE OF THIS COUNTRY.
TONIGHT, WE HAVE TO ASK
OURSELF THIS QUESTION.
WHAT HAVE THE DEMOCRATS
NANCY AND CHUCK BEEN
STANDING UP FOR?
ACTUALLY NOTHING.
THERE IS NO POSITION HERE.
THEY HAVE ONLY BEEN PLAY
INDICATING WHAT IS NOW THE
RADICAL EXTREME BASE OF THE
SOCIALIST DEMOCRATIC PARTY
OF TODAY.
AND ALL THEY DO IS FUEL
THEIR DAILY ANTI-TRUMP RAGE
AND HATE.
ASK THAT QUESTION TONIGHT.
DEMOCRATS, WHAT DO THEY DO?
THEY WENT ON VACATION.
THE PRESIDENT STAYED AT THE
WHITE HOUSE.
LUXURIOUS JUNKETS REALLY
PAID BYE BYE LOBBYISTS WHILE
THE PRESIDENT STAYS IT AT
THE WHITE HOUSE.
REFUSING INVITATION AFTER
INVITATION TO SIT DOWN WITH
THE PRESIDENT WHO IS SAYING
I'M WILLING TO WORK WITH
YOU.
I WILL WORK ON DACA AND
DREAMERS.
WE HAVE GOT TO SECURE THE
BORDER TO SAVE THE LIVES OF
OUR FELLOW COUNTRY MEN
BECAUSE OF THE PROBLEM WITH
OPEN BORDERS THESE OTHER
DEMOCRATS PRIVATELY THEY
HAVE BEEN GOING BEHIND THE
LEADERSHIP IN THEIR OWN
PARTY ASKING LEADERS LIKE
LINDSEY GRAHAM AND OTHERS,
HEY, HELP US GET THIS PERIOD
WHERE WE CAN TRY TO GET THIS
JOB DONE.
THEY WANT THE WALL AS WELL
BUT THEY ARE JUST NOT
TELLING SCHUMER AND PELOSI.
IF NOT, THEY KNOW THE
PRESIDENT WILL DECLARE THAT
NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
THE PRESIDENT, TO HIS
CREDIT, HE HAS TRIED EVERY
SINGLE THING HE COULD
POSSIBLY DO.
HE HAS BEEN REASONABLE.
HE HAS BEEN FAIR.
HE HAS OFFERED CONCESSIONS
BUT IN THE END IT'S HIS JOB
AS COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF TO
KEEP US SAFE.
HE WILL DO HIS JOB.
SO NOW CONGRESS, THEY HAVE
THEIR THREE WEEKS TO DO
THEIR JOB AND SECURE OUR
BORDER.
DEMOCRATS, WEAK KNEED
REPUBLICANS THEY NEED TO
UNREMEMBER THE FACTS.
WE HAVE BUILT SO FAR
6454 MILES OF BORDER WALL
OVER THE LAST 15 YEARS WITH
NOTABLE RESULTS.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE WALL IN
HUMA, ARIZONA, AFTER IT WENT
FROM FIVE MILES TO 60 PLUS
MILES, THAT LED TO A 91%
DROP IN CRIME REMEMBER
DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY USED TO
BE FOR STRONG BORDERS JUST A
FEW YEARS AGO.
THAT'S WHEN OBAMA WAS
PRESIDENT.
ACTUALLY, THEY SOUNDED MORE
LIKE TRUMP THAN TRUMP BEFORE
THEY WERE CONSUMED WITH ALL
THIS ANTI-TRUMP HATE AND
RAGE EVERY DAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> PEOPLE WHO ENTER THE
UNITED STATES WITHOUT OUR
PERMISSION ARE ILLEGAL
ALIENS AND ILLEGAL ALIENS
SHOULD NOT BE TREATED THE
SAME AS PEOPLE WHO ENTER THE
U.S. LEGALLY:  TO SO MANY
AMERICANS WE DO NOT WANT THE
WALL TO BE A SYMBOL OF
AMERICA.
MUCH PREFERRING THE STATUE
OF LIBERTY BE THAT SYMBOL.
>> ALL OF US AGREE THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE COMPREHENSIVE
BIPARTISAN IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
THAT CAN ONLY BEGIN STRONG
BORDER CONTROL.
WE MUST HAVE THAT.
WE MUST CONTROL OUR BORDERS.
>> A WALL IS AN IMMORALITY.
IT'S NOT WHO WE ARE AS A
STATION.
>> WALLS WORK BUT WE HAVE
GOT TO FINISH THE JOB.
I HAVE SAID SOME TIMES ON
THIS PROGRAM THE COST OF A
POROUS BORDER THEY ARE
ENORMOUS AND GROWING MORE
SERIOUS EVERY SINGLE DAY.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING, DRUG
TRAFFICKING.
GANGS, CARTELS.
IT IS A LIFE AND DEATH
SITUATION.
TALK TO ANGEL MOMS AND ANGEL
DADS.
TALK TO THE PARENTS THAT
HAVE LOST THEIR KIDS BECAUSE
OF THE OPIOID CRISIS.
THEN TO MAKE MATTERS WORSE,
ANOTHER 10,000 PERSON
MIGRANT CARAVAN RIGHT NOW AS
WE SPEAK IS HEADED OUR WAY.
SO, YOU SAY TONIGHT TO CHUCK
AND NANNIES, ALL RIGHT.
BEHIND YOUR BACK YOUR FELLOW
DEMOCRATS THEY WANT THAT
WALL.
THEY ALSO WANT A DEAL WITH
DACA.
THEY WANT TO SOLVE PROBLEMS.
THEY WANT SOLUTIONS.
WILL YOU WORK FOR IT?
NOW, YOU CAN EITHER WORK
WITH THIS PRESIDENT, DO
WHAT'S RIGHT FOR THE COUNTRY
OR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL
SEE YOU FOR WHO YOU ARE,
JUST OBSTRUCTIONISTS, HATING
A PRESIDENT.
AND ANYONE OUT THERE BY THE
WAY THINKING PRESIDENT TRUMP
CAVED TODAY, YOU DON'T
REALLY KNOW THE DONALD TRUMP
I KNOW.
HE HOLDS THE CARDS.
HE WILL SECURE THE BORDER
ONE WAY OR ANOTHER.
WHILE PRESIDENT TRUMP WORKS
HARD TO SOLVE SERIOUS ISSUES
OF LIFE AND DEATH FACING THE
COUNTRY.
WE DO HAVE ANOTHER ISSUE
TONIGHT.
HANNITY WATCH ON THE DEEP
STATE.
ROBERT MUELLER AND HIS MERRY
BAND OF DEMOCRATIC DONORS
THEY CONTINUE THEIR QUEST
LITERALLY TO DESTROY THE
LIVES OF EVERYONE AND ANYONE
THAT'S ASSOCIATED WITH
DONALD TRUMP.
TODAY ROGER STONE WAS THEIR
LATEST TARGET.
OUR OWN TRACE GALLAGHER HAS
THE VERY LATEST.
>> SEAN, PREET DAWN RAID ON
THE FORT LAUDERDALE HOME OF
LONG TIME TRUMP CONFIDANTE
ROGER STONE SHOUTED WITH THE
FBI SAYING OPEN THE DOOR.
ENDED WITH STONE BEING LED
AWAY IN HANDCUFFS.
MONTH SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT
MUELLER AND SENIOR MEMBERS
OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN TRIED
TO BENEFIT FROM THE RELEASE
OF WIKILEAKS OF HACKED
DEMOCRATIC EMAILS DAMAGING
TO THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
STONE CALLED THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED AND VOWED TO FIGHT
THE CHARGES SAYING HE WAS
FALSELY ACCUSED OF MAKING
FALSE STATEMENTS TO THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE.
HERE'S WHAT HE JUST SAID ON
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
AFTERNOON WAVE.
>> I'M IN FOR THE FIGHT OF
MY LIFE.
BUT I WILL NOT QUIT.
I WILL NOT FOLD.
I WILL NOT BEND.
I WILL NOT BEAR FALSE
WITNESS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
I INTEND TO FIGHT BECAUSE
THIS INDICTMENT IS
FABRICATED.
THIS INDICTMENT IS THIN AS
CAN BE.
>> WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY SARAH SANDERS SAY
THE CHARGES DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THE
PRESIDENT AND TRUMP ATTORNEY
JAY SEKULOW ALSO DOES NOT
ALLEGE RUSSIAN COLLUSION BY
ROGER STONE OR ANYONE ELSE
MEANING THERE IS NO EVIDENCE
THAT STONE CONSPIRES WITH
WIKILEAKS OR THE RUSSIAN
OFFICIALS HOT SPECIAL
COUNSEL BELIEVES HACKED THE
DEMOCRATIC EMAILS.
THE INDICTMENT DOES SAY THAT
STONE REPEATEDLY DISCUSSED
WIKILEAKS WITH CAMPAIGN
ASSOCIATES.
HERE HE IS AGAIN.
WATCH.
>> BUT KNOWING WHAT'S IN MY
EMAIL AND MY TEXT MESSAGES,
THERE IS NO CORROBORATION
WHATSOEVER FOR THIS.
AND AS FOR MY EMAIL EXCHANGE
WITH STEVE BANNON,
EVERYTHING I TOLD HIM IN THE
EXCHANGE WAS PUBLICLY
REPORTED INFORMATION.
>> STONE IS OBVIOUSLY OUT ON
BAIL, $250,000 BOND TO BE
EXACT.
HIS NEXT COURT DATE IS
JANUARY 29TH IN THE NATION'S
CAPITAL.
IT'S NOT UNCOMMON FOR THE
FBI TO MAKE EARLY MORNING
ARRESTS OF TARGETS UNDER
INDICTMENT FIRST TIME ROBERT
MUELLER HAS USE THUD TACTIC.
STONE HAD BEEN PREDICTING
HIS INDICTMENT FOR MONTHS.
SEAN, BACK TO YOU.
>> Sean: TRACE, THANK YOU.
WE ARE WITNESSING THE
BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER
SCANDAL IN AMERICAN HISTORY
PLAYING OUT RIGHT BEFORE
YOUR EYES.
MORE CORRUPTION THAN WE HAVE
EVER SEEN.
REALLY A PREDAWN RAID?
17 VEHICLES MOVE IN.
27 FBI AGENTS IN FULL SWAT
GEAR, GUNS DRAWN, HOME
SURROUNDED?
FOR WHAT?
ROGER STONE IS NOT BEING
CHARGED WITH ANY VIOLENT
CRIME HERE.
HE ISN'T CHARGED WITH
COLLUDING WITH A FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT AT ALL.
HE HAS NEVER POSED ANY
SECURITY THREAT OF ANY KIND.
INSTEAD HE WAS INDICTED ON A
SERIES OF PROCESS CRIMES
THAT NEVER WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED, YET, ROBERT
MUELLER STARTED AN
INVESTIGATION.
THIS IS, IN OTHER WORDS,
CREATED BY THE FACT THAT
MUELLER HAD AN
INVESTIGATION.
WHY IS HE BEING TREATED LIKE
PABLO ESCOBAR?
NATURALLY FAKE NEWS CNN THEY
WERE THERE.
THEY CAPTURED THE WHOLE
THING.
WOW, HOW DID THEY KNOW THE
EXACT TIMING OF THIS?
SOMEHOW THE NETWORKS FAKE
NEWS SO-CALLED JOURNALISTS
KNEW EXACTLY WHEN AND WHERE
THE RAID WOULD GO DOWN AND
THE TIME IT WOULD HAPPEN.
WELL, COULDN'T BE, COULD IT?
DID ONE OF, MAYBE, SOMEBODY
IN MUELLER'S OFFICE, MAYBE
ONE OF THE PARTISAN
INVESTIGATORS, I DON'T KNOW,
DID THEY TIP OFF THEIR
FAVORITE FAKE NEWS NETWORK
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ALISON THE RUSSIA TEAM
THOUGHT SOMETHING WAS
HAPPENING.
THERE WAS UNUSUAL GRAND JURY
ACTIVITY IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
YESTERDAY.
WE ALSO HAD OTHER SIGNS THAT
MAYBE SOMETHING WAS GOING ON
THIS ANGLE, THE ROGER STONE
ANGLE.
SO, WE SHOWED UP AT HIS
HOUSE THIS MORNING.
WE WERE THE ONLY ONES THERE
AND LO AND BEHOLD THE FBI
AGENTS DID COME AND ARREST
HIM.
>> Sean: MAYBE ANOTHER
INVESTIGATION INTO MORE
LEAKING?
THE DETAILS OF AN ONGOING
INVESTIGATION?
BY THE WAY THAT'S A SERIOUS
CRIME.
I WONDER IF THESE LEAKERS,
ARE THEY EVER GOING TO FACE
JUSTICE?
THAT'S RIGHT.
WE ARE LIVING IN A TWO
TIERED JUSTICE SYSTEM.
ONE IF YOU ARE A CLINTON, A
WHOLE OTHER ONE IF YOU ARE A
DEMOCRAT.
AND LIKE VIRTUALLY ALL THE
INVESTIGATORS ON MUELLER'S
TEAM, WELL, THEY SEEM ABOVE
THE LAW.
BUT IF YOU ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP, YOU
GET YOUR DOOR KICKED DOWN IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT
HAULED AWAY IN HANDCUFFS,
ALL WHILE CNN FILMS IT ALL.
YOU ARE TARRED AND FEATHERED
IN THE PUBLIC SQUARE.
YOUR INNOCENCE IS STRIPPED
BEFORE EVER FACING TRIAL.
YOUR RIGHTS ARE TRAMPLED ON
BY A POLITICALLY MOTIVATED
ARMY OF CLINTON DONORS.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
THIS BEARS ALL THE MARKINGS
OF MUELLER'S SO-CALLED PIT
BULL ANDREW WEISSMANN LIKE
ALL OF MUELLER'S PREVIOUS
TARGETS, ROGER STONE WAS NOT
CHARGED WITH ANYTHING RUSSIA
INVOLVED, NO COLLUSION, NO
RUSSIA, NO EXIRLS TO STEAL
CLINTON'S EMAILS OR COMMIT
CAMPAIGN FRAUD BECAUSE HE
DIDN'T COMMIT ANY OF THOSE
CRIMES AND ISN'T CHARGED
WITH THAT.  THAT'S WHY HE IS
CHARGED WITH SEVEN BOGUS
PROCESS CRIMES AGAIN.
FIVE COUNTS OF LYING TO
CONGRESS AND NOT ONCE LYING
ABOUT EMAILS.
OH, AND TEXT MESSAGES.
ALL OF THESE CRIMES
OCCURRING AFTER THE START OF
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
NOW, THIS IS NOTHING MORE
THAN A POLITICAL
PERSECUTION.
NOW, LET'S NOT FORGET JAMES
COMEY HE LIED TO CONGRESS.
JOHN BRENNAN LIED TO
CONGRESS.
JAMES CLAPPER LIED TO
CONGRESS ON MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS.
ARE THEY GOING TO BE
CHARGED?
WHEN WILL THEY GET THE
PREDAWN RAID TREATMENT?
WHAT ABOUT FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR ANDREW MCCABE FIRED
FOR LYING TO THE FBI?
WHEN IS HE GOING TO GET THE
PREDAWN RAID?
COMEY'S GENERAL COUNSEL
JAMES BAKER LEAKED
INFORMATION.
WHEN IS HIS PREDAWN RAID.
JAMES COMEY LEAKED MEMOS TO
THE PRESS PROFESSOR FRIEND
IS HE GOING TO GET CHARGED
WITH THAT?
BIGGEST OF ALL WE HAVE
HILLARY CLINTON.
SHE MISHANDLED TOP SECRET
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL ON AN
UNSECURED PRIVATE SERVER AND
THEN WANT TO TALK ABOUT
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE NOT
HANDING OVER EMAILS AND TEXT
MESSAGES.
OH, THAT'S WHAT THEY JUST
CHARGED ROGER STONE WITH.
HILLARY DESTROYED SUBPOENAED
EMAILS, 33,000 OF THEM.
OH, AND THEN SHE WASHED HER
COMPUTER HARD DRIVE WITH
BLEACH BIT AND THEN THEY
BUSTED UP THE DEVICES.
WHERE IS HILLARY CLINTON'S
PREDAWN RAID?
JAMES COMEY, SALLY YATES ROD
ROSENSTEIN THEY ALL LIED TO
A FISA COURT.
THEY NEVER CHECKED THE
VERACITY OF THE CHARGES IN
THE CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR FIRESTONE DOSSIER.
ARE THEY GOING TO BE CHARGED
FOR THOSE BLATANT CRIMES?
THIS IS SAD AND NOW GOING TO
BE THE END OF REAL JUSTICE
IN AMERICA BECAUSE THIS IS A
TWO TIERED SYSTEM OF JUSTICE
AND TODAY AFTER POSTING
BAIL.
ROGER STONE, HE REMAINS
DEFIANT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I WILL PLEAD NOT GUILTY
TO THESE CHARGES.
I WILL DEFEAT THEM IN COURT.
I BELIEVE THIS IS A
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED
INVESTIGATION.
I AM TROUBLED BY THE
POLITICAL MOTIVATION OF THE
PROSECUTORS AND AS I HAVE
SAID PREVIOUSLY, THERE IS NO
CIRCUMSTANCE WHATSOEVER
UNDER WHICH I WILL BEAR
FALSE WITNESS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT NOR WILL I MAKE UP
LIES TO EASE THE PRESSURE ON
MYSELF.
I LOOK FORWARD TO BE FULLY
AND COMPLETELY VINDICATED.
>> Sean: ACCORDING TO THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL, THE BASIS
FOR STONE'S ARREST AROUND
HIS ATTEMPT TO SOURCE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN EMAILS
ACQUIRD BY WIKILEAKS.
BY THE WAY THAT'S NOT A
CRIME.
I HAVE SAID IT BEFORE AND I
WILL SAY IT AGAIN.
IF TRYING TO ACCESS
WIKILEAKS INFORMATION AND
FIND OUT WHAT THEY HAD IS A
CRIME THEN ALMOST EVERY
MEDIA OUTLET IN THIS COUNTRY
WOULD BE GUILTY OF THAT
CRIME.
IN 2016 NEARLY EVERY PAPER,
EVERY NEWS ORGANIZATION
ACCESSED WIKILEAKS DOCUMENTS
SURROUNDING THE STOLEN
PODESTA EMAILS INCLUDING THE
EVER SO LOVED LIBERAL "NEW
YORK TIMES."
THEY ACTUALLY PROVIDED
DIRECT LINK TO THE EMAILS
INSIDE OF HEIR ARTICLES
WHICH BRINGS US NOW TO A
HANNITY HISTORY LESSON.
VERY SIMILAR TO A CASE IN
1971 VERY FAMOUS 'CASE KNOWN
AS THE PENTAGON PAPERS WHEN
THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
PUBLISHED A TOP SECRET
FEDERAL REPORT ON THE
VIETNAM WAR CALLED THE
PENTAGON PAPERS.
THE REPORT WAS STOLEN.
IT WAS GIVEN TO THE "TIMES"
BY FEDERAL EMPLOYEES AND
SUBSEQUENTLY PUBLISHED BY
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" AND
VARIOUS OTHER PAPERS AND
OTHER NEWS AGENCIES.
NOW, FOLLOWING AN ATTEMPTED
GOVERNMENT CRACKDOWN, THE
SUPREME COURT UPHELD THE
MEDIA'S RIGHT TO PUBLISH
WHAT ARE STOLEN PENTAGON
PAPERS.
SO ROGER STONE, ON OR ABOUT
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" OR
ANYONE ELSE WAS INTERESTED
IN KNOWING WHAT WIKILEAKS
WAS GOING TO PRODUCE NEXT,
WHICH, THEY ALL WERE.
AND LEAK IT THE CLINTON
EMAILS IN 016, THAT IS NOT A
CRIME, UNLESS, OF COURSE,
THEY STOLE IT OR CONSPIRED
TO STEAL IT WHICH THAT IS
NOT PART OF THE CHARGES.
THAT'S WHY ROGER STONE IS
ONLY FACING PROCESS CRIME
ALLEGATIONS.
FIVE COUNTS, LYING TO
CONGRESS.
AND AS YOU CAN SEE ROBERT
MUELLER FOUND ZERO EVIDENCE
OF CRIMINAL CAMPAIGN
COLLUSION.
STILL, WANTED TO TURN THE
SCREWS ANY WAY.
YOU KNOW, SO MAYBE HE WILL
TALK OR MAYBE HE WILL
COMPOSE OR SING.
SOUND FAMILIAR?
WHY?
BECAUSE MUELLER WANTS TO
TAKE DOWN A DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
HE HAS ONLY DEMOCRATS,
DONORS ON HIS TEAM.
MAYBE THEY WANT REVENGE FOR
THE 2016 ELECTION.
AND THEY APPEAR TO STOP AT
NOTHING TO GET IT.
BUT I HAVE A NEWS FLASH FOR
TEAM MUELLER.
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION.
YOUR INVESTIGATION IS